عندي مخزون استراتيجي من الرجال من هنا
بدا كل شيء بدات الظاهره التي سيدخل معها
السودان اكثر ايامه عنفا واضطرابا
[موسيقى]
في خلال اسبوعين
الدنيا كانت خريف قال لي حاضر
[موسيقى]
ما جاب 5000 بس جاب 6000
انها القوه التي تكونت من بضع عشرات ثم
اصبحت بضعه مئات يقودها الشاب العشريني
محمد حمدان
في اقليم دارفور الذي لم يعرف السلام طيله
سنوات التسعينات والعشريه الاولى من هذا
القرن نادر كان في ليبيا من تلك النواه
الميليشياويه سينمو الدعم السريع مستغلا
تناقضات السياسه والعسكريه السودانيه
ادمان حكم الرئيس عمر البشير
وليحقق طفرته الكبرى بعد الثوره التي انهت
حكمه في عام 2019 انه النمو الذي كان يجري
تحت بصر الجميع حتى اصبحت قوات الدعم
السريع جيشا ضخما ينظر اليه على انه اصبح
مهددا لكيان الدوله السودانيه
بعد الثوره لم يعد الفريق حميدتي قائدا
عسكريا مدخرا لقمع الاضطرابات والتمردات
لقد خرج على النص الذي كتبه البشير يوم
كان لا يعدوه بجمله زائده
سيصير حبيبتي نائبا برئيس المجلس العسكري
فلما قامت اول حكومه مدنيه برئاسه عبد
الله حمدوك كان حميدتي قد اتخذ موقعه
نائبا لرئيس مجلس السياده يشارك حميدتي
فيما سمته القوى المدنيه منقلاب البرهان
عليها في الخامس والعشرين من اكتوبر عام
2021 ثم سريعا ينقض يده من ذلك الذي سمته
القوه المدنيه بالانقلاب ويتبرا مما
اعتبره خطا لقد تحولت قوه الدعم السريع
الى راس مال سياسي يتزايد بازدياد توسعها
ولم يعد معها حميتي قوه عسكريه وحسب بل
اصبح في سياق سيروره تطوريه متعدده
الطفرات قدم خلالها نفسه على انه الراعي
الرسمي للمشروع الديمقراطي في السودان
والحامي له بقواته وكان قد اشترط لدمج تلك
القوات في الجيش امدا زمنيا مدته عشر
سنوات وهو ما رفضه قاده الجيش
ويبدو انه لم يكن من الحرب بد بعد ان بلغت
تناقضات العسكريه والسياسه السودانيه حدها
النهائي انه المازق الماساوي الذي انتهى
اليه السودان وكشف بتكاليفه الباهظه
تشوهات الدوله السودانيه وتواطؤ نخبتها
العسكريه والسياسيه على التعامي عن حيثيات
ما كانت لتؤدي الى غير الذي ادت اليه يقول
سودانيون ما المخرج من الوضع الراهن
المطروح امام الحكومه السودانيه وقوات
الدعم السريع
مبادرتان امريكيه سعوديه وهذه المبادره
تدعو الى تحقيق هدنه تتطور الى وقف لاطلاق
النار يحقق سرعه الاستجابه للحاجات
الانسانيه لملايين السودانيين ثم يفضي الى
محادثات بين الطرفين
وقد هاتف بشانها وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
والسعودي كلا من البرهان قائد الجيش
قائد قوات الدعم السريع ثم هناك مبادره
اخرى تقف وراءها منظمه الايجاد وهي ايضا
تدعو الى الالتزام بهدنه يعقبها ارسال
مبعوثين يمثلان القوات المتقاتله في
الخرطوم للدخول في حوار بينهما في جوبا
عاصمه جنوب السودان
واياما كانت وجاهه هذه المبادره او تلك
فان سؤالا اشكاليا سيواجه اصحاب المبادرات
بالقدر نفسه الذي سيواجه به اطراف الصراع
وهو التفاوض حول ماذا
لزم الجيش السوداني موقفا واحدا فرق فيه
بين امرين وهما امكانيه الالتزام بالغدن
لاسباب انسانيه اما الموقف الاخر فهو
تاكيده انه لا يمكن الجلوس مع قوات متمرده
على الدوله وان خياراته هي قمع التمرد اما
باستسلامه او بالقضاء عليه اما الفريق
محمد حمدان قائد الدعم السريع فيقول انه
يحارب من اجل استعاده المسار الديمقراطي
الذي قطع الطريق عليه انقلابيون وصفهم
بالاسلاميين الراديكاليين وانه سيلاحق
البرهان لتقديمه للمحاكمه لغدره بالمشروع
الديمقراطي وهو زعم قد يجد له مؤيدين من
القوه السياسيه في الداخل كما قد يجد صدى
له في الدوائر الغربيه ان لم يكن قد وجد
هل ستملك المبادرات والساعون بها القدره
على رد الازمه الى اصلها
فالفيل الذي يرعى في الغرفه هو وجود قوه
عسكريه يقول الجيش انها تمردت عليه وهددت
كيان البلاد وسلامتها وتقول هي من جانبها
انها تحمي التحول الديمقراطي وتحقيق الحكم
المدني هنا ستكون معضله اصحاب المبادرات
اذا خاضوا فيما يعنيه عمليا وجود دوله
بجيشين وفي معنى ان يتحقق تحول ديمقراطي
في كنف البنادق البنادق التي يتصل نسبها
بانظمه الله علاقه لها بالديمقراطيه يقول
الذين يردون وقائع السودان الى نظائرها في
المنطقه العربيه
والراجح لدى كثيرين ان السودان بعد الحرب
لن يكون كما كان قبلها لا في عسكريته ولا
في سياسته